[Music]
hey what's going on is Bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday November 6 2017 what's going on
how are you how are you doing no really
seriously are you okay I've been
thinking about you
is anything worse when you don't want
someone to like you know if you don't
want to talk about your [ __ ] troubles
and then there's that overly caring
person in your life that notices them
and yet they're like you know what's
what's going on you know I'm cool I'm
good I'm good no seriously you see
there's just picking up something on
your energy what do you even [ __ ]
Star Trek yeah you read my mind you know
I mean you're right I don't need you was
an on [ __ ] psychiatrist walking
around my brain everybody thinks that
[ __ ] qualified because they watched a
couple episodes of dr. Phil and he makes
it look so easy for this simple fact
that the man does not give a [ __ ] okay
he's there for one reason only all right
it's for the who is after the show you
know that's why he has that [ __ ]
angry you ever seen a guy helping more
people with such like a [ __ ] angry
look on his face you know I got the
Chiefs [ __ ] cowboys game on in the
background how many times does a special
team [ __ ] up a free lunch when the
puncher kicks it right down to the
one-yard line and they're just the worst
the guy [ __ ] did it everybody wants
to be the guy that does it and then they
[ __ ] fumble the ball into the end
zone you know what happens not the
punter takes the hit and then rather
than him having a 41-yard [ __ ]
average for the game it moves down to 38
right and the second they see that three
all of a sudden they want to move you to
another team nobody nobody ever looks at
the nameless [ __ ] that run down the
[ __ ] field the wedge breakers all of
them right the guys that nobody has
talked about since John Madden stop
announcing games they go down there and
consistently [ __ ] that play up this has
nothing to do with NFL special teams
this has nothing to do with people
asking me how are you doing is
everything good you look good but high
sense of sadness it's just like can you
just can you just [ __ ] let me sit
here all right wait I'm ready to talk
about this it's like this isn't yours to
talk about right anyways can say anyways
one more [ __ ] time
my last podcast I left you I was at the
Surf ballroom right Chantilly lace and a
pretty face a ponytail hanging down a
wiggle and a walker and a Google Lunar
talk I was there me the world will bow
wow wow wow and the next day I was
flying air choice one to Chicago and
then I was taking another puddle jumper
up - what the hell was in Milwaukee
right so me and Dean Delray we show up
we had like the greatest [ __ ] night
ever we stayed at this hotel that was
designed by Frank Lloyd Webber amazing
hotel so we drive up to the airport the
airport the Mason City Airport is just a
great
well greatest thing ever I want to I'm
gonna upload some pictures you walk in
this there's probably 12 chairs for
people in the waiting room you go
through this little security area I love
little airports little mom-and-pop
airports I get up there Dean checks in
all good
I go to check-in I'm on the 9:25 I land
in Chicago O'Hare I have a little loaf
of fun you know a little layover and
then I'm gonna go up to then I'm gonna
go up to the you know up to Milwaukee
right for my 7 what I thought was a 7:30
show turned out it was at 7 so I get in
there and the lady behind the counter
goes I you're not flying until 5:25 and
that was like that is impossible I won't
be and you know I won't be in Milwaukee
in time for my show she goes well
according to this
you're on the 525 I go alright well is
there room on the 925 so I can switch
flights she goes no I'm sorry that's
sold out so immediately you know me with
my temper I go oh so what so what that
one's sold out so you bumped me to the
next flight and she just she just stuck
her hand out like when your dad used to
say cooling right she just stuck her
hand out and she just goes alright we
don't do that here
alright starts [ __ ] giving me [ __ ]
back and start saying that I screwed up
I mean like what do you mean AIESEC how
do you know I scoop I got a confirmation
number I got all this type of stuff and
she goes we don't do that there go okay
so you guys never mess up you never mess
up this is on me my travel agent never
screws up right we going back and forth
back and forth and she's such [ __ ]
yelling at me and I'm you know I'm
keeping my voice I'm definitely you know
definitely on my toes but I'm not
yelling but she's yelling at me a
raising a voice and finally I just said
to her I said lady why are you yelling
at me okay I'm the one who's getting
screwed yeah yeah your shift ends at
whatever time it ends it's no skin off
your back I'm not yelling I'm not
swearing why you swearing right I'm not
yelling why are you yelling at me she
got all [ __ ] pissed and I was just
like Jesus Christ I thought people were
friendly in Iowa that's what I heard
right so now I have to get a [ __ ]
rental car and I have to drive from
Clear Lake you know I called my people
up up above everybody's trying to figure
out what the [ __ ] going on so well now
I got a rental I got a rent up goddamn
car in Clear Lake Iowa and I have to
drive from Clear Lake Iowa all the way
to Milwaukee which is going to be
nothing but [ __ ] cow pastures you
know what I mean I'll tell what's
amazing is that anybody could crash and
die in Iowa that's what I took away from
this [ __ ] Drive because all I see is
it's just a giant it's just a giant
field you know
sorry anyways so I called my travel
agent we go to [ __ ] figure out I
don't know what I don't know what
happened it turns out it was somewhere
on my end somebody [ __ ] up so I walked
up to the lady and I said listen I
apologize
I actually apologize to what I just said
it was it was somebody on my end where
can I get the rental car and then I just
had to [ __ ] deal with that [ __ ] and
the stupid thing said it was a five hour
something minute drive and I just got in
the [ __ ] car and drove like 80 85 the
entire way I averaged 79 miles an hour
that was with no stops no no getting gas
but you know whenever a truck gets in
the left lane and tries to pass up a
hill that [ __ ] the next 20 minutes see
a life up you know but uh anyways ended
up making it there my apologies to the
lady you know who could have been a
little nicer you know I think I brought
it out of her all right but I will tell
you this
okay you know people tell me how
friendly everybody is in Iowa I'm
telling till you question what it is
that don't then all of a sudden they get
their backs up or I met one of the few
angry people out there I don't know
Slipknot's from Iowa it's not exactly
happy-go-lucky music is it so I [ __ ]
drove all the way into Milwaukee like a
maniac because I wanted to get to my
favorite hotel in the United States of
America which is the Pfister hotel I
swear to god it's called the Pfister
it's the last name of this family
spelled PFI s ter if you are ever in
Milwaukee that is where you stay you
stay at the Pfister all right it was
Guido Pfister had the idea for it and
his kid came through with it you know
this was the 1800s when his last thing
was Pfister
all right somehow they say they were
German but his first name is Guido
I mean is it Phi ster
all I know it's as far as I know I think
fisting had died down in the 1800s so
you could have that as a last name but I
believe in Roman times
according to like movies movies like
Caligula that was going on but now with
all the sexual harassment and evidently
all these [ __ ] lunatic perverts slash
rapists in Hollywood I love that they're
acting like this is specific to
Hollywood that's something they do all
the time like if there's like an NFL
player that gets busted for domestic
violence they go what is with these
athletes beating women and it's like it
it's that's not it this is just a
microcosm of the just a little sample of
humanity
I would I would actually will not be
willing to bet that there's just as many
plumbers out there that get accused of
domestic violence as football players or
whatever it's just that plumbers don't
sell out football stadiums there's not a
giant plumber stadium to see you know a
first-ballot Hall of Fame plumber
plumber sink so nobody pays attention so
everybody gets to act like oh it's it's
going on it's in Hollywood it's it's
it's over here like they always notice
what people on television are doing you
know I mean look at Bill Clinton I mean
okay this guy comes on a [ __ ] fern
and he's blowing a load on a dress which
is standard I guess that's more that's
more pedestrian plays for your jizz to
end up you know if you're going to sit
there in court you know and your lawyer
is gonna be going hard this is gonna be
a little bit of an embarrassing day for
you there buddy they're gonna bring your
jizz in and you know but it's on a dress
so I'm willing to bet that a number of
people you know that are in the jury at
some point have splurged on a dress you
know it very least one of their own
t-shirts you know let's not forget about
tube socks but that you know that goes
without saying
right it's but then you know if you're
on trial and you you did it into a plant
you know that's a little weird a plant
is different than you know if you [ __ ]
outside because then you're just outside
but a plant is just really specific you
know I thought Hollywood was green I
thought they gave a [ __ ] about the
environment anyways I don't want the
[ __ ] I'm talking about so yeah it's it's
an unbelievable like this [ __ ] hotel
you could have shot the shining in there
I mean that in a good way not in the
creepy way because as creepy as that
movie is that is a beautiful hotel and
it's basically a album upload some
pictures of that too but it's like
literally something that Stanley Kubrick
could have filmed one of his
masterpieces in and also they have the
greatest sickest death-defying steam
room in the country I know all is this
really sonic bad Pfister steam room
trust me it's all aboveboard
it's just if you go there this is how it
works the steam comes on for seven
minutes you're gonna be in everything
for twenty minutes or 1/2 hour if you
get the half hour one it comes on for
seven minutes
okay and it's literally like a steam
pipe broke and I had to get underneath
the towel because what you want to do is
just let all that steam come in you got
to tough it out for seven minutes all
right because it's not gonna come on
again until the final seven if you got
the 30-minute one twenty minutes it
never comes on again so as hot as it
gets you got to know that that steam has
to last for the entire time that you're
in there and there's a shower there's
like you got your own private place and
there's a shower down the end of it so
this the first day I went in there I
[ __ ] I opened the window a little bit
because I couldn't take it anymore and
then I closed it when it started to die
down I realized that let all the steam
out and then four minutes later it was
borderline chilly in there so I was like
[ __ ] I screwed it up I said oh so
tomorrow when I get there I'm just gonna
tough this [ __ ] out right and I was
under a towel like four and a half
minutes in literally going
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] and I just couldn't take it
anymore cells like don't open the window
run to the other side and turn on the
shower right it's like an old ahead show
and you have it on cold and I went over
there and it was like half a degree not
as hot like the steam you know I ran by
the steam thing and now my [ __ ] legs
felt like I actually understand now what
it feels like
initially when you're on fire because
you know what you want to do but you
can't do it because you're too busy
hopping up and down so I'm literally
hopping up and down within it I want to
turn on the shower but I had to like I
was reacting to the panga laughs and the
the handle was right there and I just
kept reaching down patting at my legs
rather than just reaching over and turn
it on the thing so finally I had to
block out the pain for like 0.2 seconds
reach over and turn on the [ __ ] thing
and of course the last person that was
in there left it on hot after you know
the steam was over and they took a hot
shower so it came out hot and I was like
[ __ ] back down to get it down to cold
and I just stood there for the final
three and a half minutes dude it is no
joke and the half hour was done like I
walked out of that thing and I was like
breathing heavy I was coming out like
like coming out I was [ __ ] all red
right so I I go out into the way you
know then you cool off for like 15
minutes and you just sitting there and
you aren't you're not thinking about
anything you're just sitting there
totally relaxed you feel [ __ ] amazing
while in the back he had going like you
know I don't know if that was healthy or
not right so then I go out of the steam
room right the lady comes back and get
you and I go to the waiting room and
Bartnik is already there and he just
looks at me and he starts laughing right
because I'm all [ __ ] red and I got
the shaved head he goes dude you look
like the flash
[Music]
which is hilarious because when I looked
at myself in the mirror I mumbled out
loud like I look like if Hellboy in
Jason Voorhees had a kid is that the
name of the guy from [ __ ] Friday the
13th when he you know when he comes up
out of the lake now when he pulls the
mask up alright I'm not that ugly but
I'm just saying and we just sat there
just like drinking water and everything
and you know I got to be honest with you
two days in a row of doing that the next
night I had two shows at the Riverside
Theatre just a magical [ __ ] place
that is and the comedy crowds in
Milwaukee they're they're unbelievable I
cannot say enough good things about that
city it might be my favorite city in the
country and I had two shows and like
after I got three-quarters way through
my first show and I was feeling like to
hydrated like I was like after two days
of that level of intensity I was like I
really should have crushed a bunch of
waters here you know virzi told me drank
a Gatorade and was talking about
electrolytes you know he's like you got
to do that get the electrolytes going
and I vaguely remember seeing on the
internet that electrolytes really isn't
a think that's just something that
Gatorade came up with so let me look
this up I mean I don't want to challenge
Paul Versys medical degree but uh I
don't know if electrolytes is
electrolytes a thing here are
electrolytes
oh [ __ ] you want there's a lie in there
there it is our electrolytes real all
right now there's all kinds of
electrolytes but the most important ones
are sodium chloride potassium oh they
are real I thought that that was like
something like you know rather than one
it's not a diamond they call it a DML
you know genuine diamonds like what what
the [ __ ] is a diam L well it's like a
diamond except it's not worth anything
oh I'd like one of those I thought an
electrolyte dude what the f is an
electrolyte is Gatorade the real deal
all right everybody loves Gatorade so
let's talk about if it's fluff or
actually good for you all you hear about
is rehydrate this an electrolyte that is
it for real your body has a balance and
has an ionic solution boring term don't
worry about it I want to know what it is
des and I has weight and has ionic
solutions called electrolytes to keep
your body muscles and nerves functioning
properly
your kidneys exist to help keep your
body in balance by regulating the fluids
and electrolytes in your body yeah they
filter they filter the fluids in your
body right I thought it was just
literally the liquids that you ingest
isn't it unbelievable that I don't know
how the [ __ ] body works I mean not
that you guys think I'm smart I know you
know that I'm dumb but you would think
that if you would know how that would
work right your kidneys make okay I hate
this word your kiddies make pee I hate
when adults say pee unless they're
talking to a child like do you have to
go pee pee when adults says I have to
pee I I can't handle it all right I got
to go to the bathroom just say that all
right
your kidneys make you know piss that's
disgusting though pisses pisses crest
pee is like you know you gotta walk it
off when an adult says that to you you
never a guy say that to you hey can you
pull over here I have to pee I mean he
might as well just given you like a back
rub
maybe it's not that bad anyways they
basically filter your blood so you can
get rid of waste products like urea and
ammonia ammonia somebody trying to kill
me the [ __ ] that I get some ammonia I
really need to know how this [ __ ] works
shouldn't I as I'm heading into my 50s
by the way Drive for my 50s I'm not
gonna drink until I'm 60 I've decided
that I made that decision I know I know
I'll never make it anyways when you are
dehydrated your kidneys make your pee as
concentrated as possible to keep water
in the body okay what does that mean
when you are well hydrated your kidneys
let more water leave with the waste now
there's all kinds of electrolytes but
the most important ones are sodium
chloride potassium bio carbonate calcium
right here this is me in high school I'm
not passing this class ii like the
teachers writing this on the sodium
chloride potassium stop writing bio
carbonate oh that's over and phosphate
your kidneys have specific transporters
to regulate the concentrations of each
of these electrolytes in your blood you
know I'm gonna ask Paul tonight I'm
gonna ask him I'm gonna set him up I'm
gonna say Paul did you really feel
better drinking the Gatorade afterward
he's gonna be like absolutely a thousand
percent and I said what is it do
replaces what is his replacement he's
gonna say electrolytes and I'm gonna say
Paul what are electrolytes and I
guarantee you there's no [ __ ] way
he's gonna be like you know it's the
it's the [ __ ] in your your system you
know so you don't get like leg cramps
it'll immediately have to go to the NFL
and think about people like legs
cramping up that sounds to be a name for
that because I do that all the time like
you can you can give an informed answer
while still not knowing what the [ __ ]
you're saying it's like what's-his-face
Tony Romo said this guy has a high
football acumen and I'm like what the
hell is that
the [ __ ] is a high football acumen an
acumen is having good judgment and quick
I don't know
quick decision-making in a particular
field so it's kind of insulting you know
what I mean he's saying like you know if
he could be still saying this guy's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] but if you get him on the
football field like he knows this [ __ ]
he's like the Rain Man when he gets out
there right so now that he said hi
football acumen all the mouth-breathers
that watch sports like myself can you
you know you understand you you've this
like I don't know what the word is like
you're the rhythm you know where to
place that word without actually knowing
without being able to give a definition
the only reason why I could give a
definition because I looked it up
because I never heard it because I want
to make a joke on Twitter about it right
like dota it's his [ __ ] acumen kid
you're gonna start hearing that in
sports bars and then you can you can
replace high football you can just any
subject he has a high gardening acumen
without ever looking up acumen you know
you could just just keep replacing that
the whatever the what is that the
subject here's a high serial killer
acumen so I feel electrolyte is one of
those words we just keep watching the
Gatorade commercial and it's telling you
that it's it's helping to replace
electrolytes and you know and then
enough times you just like yeah you know
you're just repeating the advertising
you know what the [ __ ] it means like I
know that Gatorade is thirst aid for
that deep down body thirst but I don't
know what thirst aid is it's aiding your
thirst or is that just all one word
Gatorade thirst aid you know you know
like when rappers do that when they want
to make something rhyme and they'll just
take the the suffix of another word they
just do [ __ ] ten words in a row like
that and you just want to be like I
always want to be all white in that
moment like excuse me mr. MC those
aren't words those aren't words you're
inventing words it's weird because I
know what they mean but those aren't
words
you will not get credit for that rap I'm
sorry well not in my cul-de-sac you
won't well it's the reason to get angry
anyway so let's finish reading this this
is actually [ __ ] interesting to me
how much I don't know your kidneys have
a specific transfer to regulate the
concentration of each of these
electrolytes in your blood when you
workout you sweat yep four years of
college taught me that this kids trying
to be funny
when you workout you sweat when you
sweat you lose fluids and electrolytes
especially sodium and chloride which is
why your sweat tastes salty now when
you're lacking fluids and electrolytes
your muscles suffer and you pray yes
it's basically like a car leaking oil
let's talk about why Gatorade or any
sports drink works water will get into
your bloodstream faster when it's part
of Gatorade because water flows follows
electrolytes Gatorade has electrolytes
so it has salt and [ __ ] in there
chloride potassium
I know potassium in like bananas but I
thought chloride was like some [ __ ] that
either cleans your your clothes or it
sounds too much like chlorine like that
seems like that would be poisonous
calcium calcium deposits on your teeth I
don't like calcium is calcium is in like
[ __ ] broccoli phosphate like fun I
would think phosphate is like you know
when you turn the car on your garage
carbon dioxide and phosphate get into
your system well actually a high a too
high level of any of these electrolytes
could prove fatal theoretically what
your body is is a symphony of balance
I'm not passing this class when you work
out all right so I think I kind of know
what the [ __ ] this [ __ ] is well I guess
I guess it's true I didn't think it was
Jesus wasn't that a long boring trip
down to [ __ ] nowhere anyway so I get
to Milwaukee
I finally got to see the bronze Fonz you
know happy days took place there I took
a picture that I'm gonna tweet out later
today of how uh Richie and Fonzie have
finally back together again before every
[ __ ] on Twitter goes yeah you [ __ ]
look like Ralph Malph I'd say more Ralph
Malph
laughing my ass off by myself at my own
joke that I wrote with my thumbs
I finally went to the harley-davidson
museum Jesus Christ you got to do that
you got to do that this is how great
Milwaukee is actually told people
Milwaukee that I wasn't gonna tell
people how great it is but I kind of
have to because it's [ __ ] amazing
because most people won't listen anyways
right all the Yolo douches you know
they're gonna go to Chicago maybe you
know go to a Cubs game you know they're
pop collar or whatever the [ __ ] it is
they do but they're gonna go to they're
gonna go to the party cities if you're
in your 20s you're not going to
Milwaukee right I don't know what they
do whatever these [ __ ] DJ's play
that's where they go when they go into
Vegas they go into Miami
they're gonna one of those places right
where the base never stops BAM you know
they have the harley-davidson museum
they have my favorite [ __ ] beer
Millett the miller brewery company is
right there you can take a tour of it I
wish I was drinking I would have done
that because they get you like you know
borderline shit-faced before you leave
and they got the Riverwalk next time I
go out there I'm going out there during
the stir in the summer Milwaukee is
basically Chicago with like you know
[ __ ] half the population all the same
stuff all the same great views without
the traffic I love it
then I the O'Brien the Monday morning
Photoshop gentleman is from out that way
and he [ __ ] let us know about some
spots to go to and it was he told us
about this place Vanguard which makes
these [ __ ] brats and sausages and
they were just next-level
they were the best sausages I've ever
had all right to keep with the
homoerotic theme of this podcast right
we had the Pfister hotel we had a steam
room and now I'm talking about sausage
[Laughter]
and evidently this is my favorite place
to go so hey maybe I'll come out like
Kevin Spacey I'm just gonna make sure I
you know I can t get this just this this
it's a very thin [ __ ] line to walk
there where the comedy exists at the end
of the day you know it's just jesus
[ __ ] christ what is going on anyways
where else what else don't I want to
talk about yeah so we just had the best
time and me virzi and bartnik just kept
saying they're like I [ __ ] love this
city city is awesome and I don't say
this about a lot of places but I that's
a I could literally live there my big
[ __ ] thing though is is I'm just
really sick of living where my sports
teams aren't you know I've been behind
enemy lines as far as being a sports fan
goes since 1995 and you know recently I
went back to Boston I remember I went
back for the [ __ ] I think I went to a
Bruins game or something yeah what - a
bronze can that's right
I was I did one day on I so when I did
well I did one day in a movie I can't
remember anymore the [ __ ] I was there
what they have during hockey season
that's what I remember
and I went to a Bruins game and I'll
never forget I looked out the hotel room
window and all I saw was a sea of Bruins
jerseys and I was just like oh my god I
forget what this feels like
and that's the one thing that I don't
know that would be the only things star
than I don't know if I could exist in
this business living there in Milwaukee
but uh I don't know it's [ __ ] fresh
air I like it
I [ __ ] I don't know why I have no idea
all right bill we get it we get it all
right
let's read a little bit of advertising
here for you know what [ __ ] that let's
talk about the [ __ ] Iowa hawkeye's
beating the [ __ ] [ __ ] of the Ohio
State Buckeyes what happened
the Buckeyes had that huge win last week
against Penn State I saw j-law head at
the all things comedy [ __ ] festival
and the man was literally floating
floating across the goddamn room the man
simply could not believe it couldn't
believe his good fortunes he was saying
that was probably the most impressive
win of the college football season and
you would be very hard-pressed to come
up with an argument different two
different you know and then a week
[ __ ] later they absolutely [ __ ] the
bed again I mean got that [ __ ] kicked
out of him if they didn't do that dumb
fake punt whatever the hell that punter
was doing then would have been like 55
17 they just shut him down in the second
half it was I was unbelievable and then
Penn State loses again too
so what does that mean what does that
mean meanwhile Wisconsin's [ __ ]
undefeated and everybody's gonna be like
well this [ __ ] nobody there's nobody
on the west we got Michigan we got our
outstay we got [ __ ] Michigan's day we
got Penn State guy Greg well you know
what they got out west they got the
[ __ ] Iowa Hawkeyes
how cool did that Stadium look whenever
I watched Iowa write play football I
don't know why I always think back when
I I liked Iowa when I was a kid because
it was a running back Ronnie Harmon that
I really liked and I brought it up to
this guy when I was on the plane taking
the Puddle Jumper over and he brought up
how he [ __ ] fumbled four times in a
Rose Bowl or some [ __ ]
and I had no idea that I didn't even
know that happened and then there was
this whole [ __ ] scandal trying to say
that
that he fixed the game because he'd like
never fumbled ever and then he fumbled
four times in the first half and I maybe
was just a bad time to have a bad game
and I never knew that about him but he
had a great NFL career Russ felt like
eighty five hundred yards almost ten
thousand yards played like eleven years
or something like that
I don't know anyways I'm getting off the
beaten track here let's do a little
advertising here all right it's time all
here we go all zip but girl are you
hiring well are you do you don't where
to post your job to find the best
candidates the zip recruiter you can
post your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards with just one click
so you can rest easy knowing your job is
being seen by the right candidates then
zip puts it's smart matching technology
to work actively notifying qualified
candidates about your job within minutes
of posting so you can receive the best
possible matches you can get a head
start on the interview process by adding
screening questions to your job to post
wait to your job post to help identify
the most qualified candidates so you
don't have to waste your time sorting
through a stack of resumes to find the
perfect fit no wonder 80% of employees
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate through the site in just one
day and the easy to use if dodge
dashboard lets you manage your hiring
process from start to finish all in one
place find out today why zip recruiter
has been used by growing businesses of
all sizes and industries to find the
most qualified job candidates with
immediate results and right now my
listeners can post job on zip for free
that's right free just go to zip
recruiter com / birth at zip recruiter
doc confer one more time hey try it for
free go to zip recruiter comp slash burp
sorry I can't keep doing different
voices I got to do a show here tonight
I'm gonna [ __ ] blow up my voice yeah
oh my god Dollar Shave Club dude they
have a
I shave an acumen kid you've heard me
talk about the amazing shave I get from
Dollar Shave Club races especially when
I use their dr. coffees easy shave
butter well I'm here to tell you I'm
never gonna give up my membership
they're gonna have to pry it from my
cold dead [ __ ] fingers in fact I'm
adding even more Dollar Shave Club
products to my daily routine dollar
Shake Club makes products for your hair
your face your skin you shower your dog
your wife your cousin your [ __ ]
everything you need they have been
looking and feeling amazing
and it's all their own original stuff
they only use the finest premium
ingredients and they deliver it to you
just like they do their raises that
means no more annoying trips to the
[ __ ] store cruising up and down the
aisles right seeing the old people
looking for [ __ ] for old people just
reminding you that you're gonna die
someday I used all the shake club for
almost everything do i razors body
cleansers hair gel I don't use the hair
gel I don't have any hair what am i
[ __ ] gel in my pubes over and yes even
the butt wipes and now it's a great time
to give Dollar Shave Club a try you can
try it you can get your first month of
their amazing best razor and with travel
sized versions of the shave butter body
cleanser and yes even the butt wipes
just for five dollars and then after
that replacement cartridges ship just
for a few bucks a month
it's the Dollar Shave Club static it get
yours for just five dollars exclusively
at dollarshaveclub.com / / that's jolly
shave club dot-com / bar and lastly but
not leastly stamps calm everybody stamps
save you time and money
which you need to grow your business
evidently I can mail any letter any
package just using my computer and
printer and the mailman comes and picks
it up avoid the hassle man of going to
the post office and mailing everything
from postcards to envelopes avoid the
hassle of going to the post office and
mail everything from postcards and
envelopes to
packages domestic or international right
from your own goddamn house
great you stamps calm create your stamps
account in minutes online with no
equipment to lease and no long term
commitments click print mail and you're
done unlike the post office stamps calm
never closes print postage for letters
or packages at your convenience 20 point
zone I use stamps calm anytime I'm
sending my posters up and right now I'm
a [ __ ] if I can figure it out so can
you and right now you can enjoy
stamps.com service with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale without long
term commitments we ain't go when
nowhere go to stamps calm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in birth that stamps calm and
to bar stamps calm never go to the post
office again oh that's what I got to
promote this I am gonna be in New York
City okay and I will be doing a special
secret top secret show then I'm not even
promoting on my website I'm just
promoting here on my podcast unless of
course we don't sell the place out then
we'll open it up to everybody else but
this this is your reward for listening
to my podcast alright I'm gonna be at a
new comedy club that's in New York City
it's called the Westside comedy club and
you can make I guess you can get tickets
at their website which is W they're not
they're not live yet so relax alright
they're gonna go live Monday November 6
which should be the day you're listening
to this even though I'm taping it on the
fifth Monday November 6th at noon
Eastern Time and I will be performing at
the Westside comedy club on Sunday
November 12th so tickets go on sale
Monday November 6th and the show is at 8
o'clock
it's Sunday November 12th at the
Westside comedy club which is at 201
West 75th Street and I think that's it
all right so
check that out it's a perfect size place
it looks awesome
it's right next to the Beacon Theater
it's a little hundred seat thing I'm
gonna be doing about 4045 minutes trying
out some new [ __ ] [ __ ] around having
a good time you know keeping the hour
tight and that's it it's a couple
friends of mine that are owning and
running the club from my days way back
we're going back to like the Boston
comedy club and that type of [ __ ]
so anyways check that out if you got a
chance and is that everything that I
want to talk about I think so can we go
into the questions for the week
how long into this vodka oh 39 minutes
okay that's perfect that is perfect I
think I could run my mouth for another
dude what the [ __ ] was LSU doing against
Alabama
I know its Alabama because they drop
more goddamn passes they actually had a
highlight reel of them [ __ ] up passes
blowing opportunities okay I gotta be
asking myself how good is the Alabama
Crimson Tide considering they're playing
in a much weaker SEC than we've seen in
years who knows but I'll tell you why
they're great because even though that
they were winning easily against LSU for
the most for most of the game Nick Saban
was still getting pissed screaming and
yelling he knows he knows he sees enough
drop passes he's like well if they
caught that and they caught that you
know this game could be this you don't
get credit cuz they dropped it you get
credit if you knock it down then he
feels like we're playing good defense
that is why that is why that guy's the
[ __ ] but it will be interesting to see
because a few weeks ago it looked like
Penn State was world beaters now they've
lost two in a row Ohio State looked like
they were coming on then they got the
living [ __ ] they got the living there
was a live [ __ ] in them and it was
kicked out of them they got to feel a
lot lighter after that's this past
weekend
alright let's uh let's do a little
questions here for the rest of the
podcast all right plastic-surgery all
right bill I watched your specials every
single day Jesus to take a break I
appreciate it but you know
you know at some point you gonna start
hating me it's not gonna be my fault all
right I have a wonderful time and I
laugh to the jokes as if I've seen them
for the first time I live in China and
YouTube is a [ __ ] here lol Wow the [ __ ]
out of here
that's amazing good luck waiting for
your new stug s Tugg I don't know what
that means but hey what's up person from
China when I was training to get my
pilot's license I flew with a bunch of
your countrymen who came over here
barely spoke English and then learned
how to fly helicopters one of the most
amazing things ever because I don't
think I could go to mainland China right
I mean you have an instructor my buddy
said to me I go they don't understand
English how do you how do you
communicate and he said they understand
tone which is what I would understand if
I was over there that's going I'll be
all right all right don't do what I just
did got it
all right JFK files old Billy root beer
float oh I love a root beer float I love
a root beer float I never get him
because I don't want to be a fat [ __ ] oh
the Cowboys throw a pick six Wow oh that
wasn't it was that a pick six
no it wasn't they didn't throw a pick
six that was actually an offensive play
why did that guy look like a cornerback
to me I can't as Kansas City gonna do it
this year everybody is Andy Reed finally
gonna bring a team to the promised land
and hoist the trophy it's up in the air
this year which once again you look how
bad the [ __ ] Giants are I don't
understand how you have a coach how you
have a GM how you have these guys in
place that got you trophies trophies
Super Bowl trophies plural and you get
rid of them it's like the Red Sox with
[ __ ] Theo Epstein and you know
[ __ ] Terry Francona we get rid of
those guys
and then literally there's a World
Series with Theo Epstein scubs and Terry
Francona's [ __ ] Indians last year I
you know I don't understand it
it's almost like morning radio like
morning radios another thing that I
watch and I just see these great shows
and the two hosts end up inevitably
hating each other and then the great
show goes away and I'm not just talking
about the one that I did it happens all
the time and I think that that's just
what happens it's nobody's fault it's
just I don't know the same way you know
after a while you're like even though
you have shirts you want a new shirt I
think people do that with like
relationships and that's what's so
[ __ ] up about marriage is it's that
same goddamn shirt and as much as you're
looking at your wife going that's that
same old shirt you got understand you're
a [ __ ] old shirt - alright and the -
you have to hold on to each other until
God takes you to Goodwill
all right JFK it's so stupid all right
JFK files old Billy root beer float oh
god damn it I love a root beer float
I'm sure you've you have heard that that
the JFK files or some of them have been
released and as a fellow conspiracy
theorist I thought this might interest
you dude they're not gonna release
anything if somebody else really did it
and they actually know who did it then I
could be like all right I think it's
safe to tell you that the guy who really
did it was not named Lee Harvey Oswald
his name was Larry [ __ ] whatever the
Larry fellowship in one of the files the
CIA states that it planned bombings in
Miami to kill innocent people
so that they can blame it on Fidel
Castro now that there is undeniable
proof that the CIA isn't above killing
innocent innocence to get their way does
that change your views on any other
conspiracy theories I know how much you
suck at reading so I attached the link
with the actual snippet of what I'm
talking about
yeah I mean I'd have to see that that
was you know you know it's interesting I
just clicked on that and all of a sudden
I'm not I'm not hooked up to the
Internet
how weird is that I was hooked up into
the Internet until I tried to look at
this [ __ ] thing now I'm basically
taking your word that that's actually
what happened if that is in fact the
case okay we could develop a communist
Cuban terror campaign in the Miami era
in other Florida cities and even
Washington the terror campaign could be
pointed at Cuban refugees seeking haven
in the United States we could sink a
boatload of Cubans enroute to Florida
real or simulated what the [ __ ]
real or simulated in other words they
they own enough they could just say it
happened and how do people know it
didn't we could foster attempts on lives
of Cuban refugees in the United States
even to the extent of wounding in
instance what even to the extent of
wounding and instances to be able to be
widely publicized exploding a few
plastic bombs and carefully chosen spots
well instead of seen it sound like
they're gonna [ __ ] kill fellow
Americans I think that they're gonna
kill Cuban refugees are exploding a few
plastic bombs at carefully chosen spots
the arrest of Cuban agent and the
release of prepared documents
substantiating cuban involvement also
would be helpful in projecting the idea
of an irresponsible government yeah none
of that surprising I mean is that really
surprising if you just sort of [ __ ]
pay attention and just even just even
remotely try to read between the lines
yeah
we're not as good as we act like we are
but I'm also not going to then glorify
Fidel Castro like he was this [ __ ]
Saint but you know I don't think it's
crazy to say that you know we were more
upset with Fidel Castro not because he
was you know a communist it was probably
more because he wouldn't let us develop
his country the way we saw fit and by we
I don't mean the average [ __ ] person
walking down the street I'm talking
about the corporations and I don't think
that that policy has changed and I'm not
going to get on a [ __ ] stump here but
I don't think that that has changed at
all and and currently that philosophy
has bankrupted this country and I don't
know what's gonna happen and that's all
really heavy [ __ ] and I you know I
remember reading something that J Edgar
Hoover allegedly said even if they do
figure out it's so [ __ ] overwhelming
and depressing they won't want to think
about it and that's where I get to so I
just go to Milwaukee and I get a brat
and I have a good time and I'd be the
dancing monkey that I am and I just hope
that the lie is able to sustain itself I
don't know I don't know I don't want the
[ __ ] to do I don't know yeah so that's
great so that's why I kind of backed
away from conspiracy theory because
because you don't want to be right even
remotely so anyway so let's get out of
that oh let's let's talk a robot granted
citizenship oh my god out of the frying
pan into the fire
I would love to read the declassified
CIA file on [ __ ] what the hell they
plan to do with robots I mean there's no
[ __ ] way that they're not talking
like I always joke God they never
discussed the population problem they
absolutely [ __ ] do but not to the
general public because it would freak
him out because I think at that point
you realize how overpopulated we are and
how expendable you are I mean that's how
I would feel
you know how many stand-up [ __ ]
comedians I mean for the survival of
humanity do you really need another one
alright robot granted citizenship
greetings from Austin you illiterate
piece of [ __ ]
alright well hello hello to you and your
[ __ ] overpopulated [ __ ] city keep
it weird you shouldn't keep it well you
should keep it weird by [ __ ]
preventing more people from moving to
that great place and ruining it I ran
across the I ran across this the other
day and thought of your podcast they
gave a robot citizenship her name is
Sofia and she was acknowledged as a
citizen in Saudi Arabia you know what
that's [ __ ] great that's [ __ ]
great because what they just did was
they ended their country that's over the
second is a robot is becomes a citizen
that is beginning that is the beginning
of the [ __ ] end the beginning of the
[ __ ] end of your goddamn what it was
that a special teams [ __ ] touch now I
don't know what's going on anyways
that's the beginning of the entry of
your country and considering from what
I've read that these terrorist groups
for the most part are funded through
Saudi Arabia sending money funneling
them through mosques I think that'd be a
good thing you know now if we could just
stop trying to build Starbucks over
there and just [ __ ] come home you
know just walk away from it instead of
being that degenerate gambler sitting at
the [ __ ] blackjack table waiting for
the cards to turn around alright so they
did this not exactly the best spot for a
female human Oh Saudi Arabia maybe they
will be nicer to robots okay this is
scary how goddamn creepy is that thing I
know this will freak you out bill just
fast forward to any point where the
robot is talking yeah I watched it you
guys got to see this video and I love
how the journalist asks acts like he's
asking these hard hit
[ __ ] questions as if these questions
weren't written out for this [ __ ]
sellout human piece of [ __ ] which is
what you have to say now this human sold
out other humans to this non [ __ ]
human life-form
what the [ __ ] are we doing he actually
says well how do we know that we can
trust you or something like how do we
know you're not gonna blah blah blah
like just like ass like a comedy team
just lobs the setup over and then the
robots like you're watching too much
Elon Musk and Hollywood movies and then
he's like oh it made a joke oh I see its
friendly it's like it's not a person it
doesn't have a heart it doesn't have a
[ __ ] soul that is a programmed
[ __ ] response alright and they're
gonna have it have all these facial
expressions to make you feel [ __ ] [ __ ]
that is that thing is is our replacement
without a doubt without a doubt and I
definitely think the robots are gonna
kill us I don't think they're literally
maybe gonna kill us but I think they
will kill us off the way the car killed
off you know the horse is a mode of
transportation which was probably cool
for the horse because he's probably sick
of us being on his back right but I
don't think it's gonna be cool for us
because we will become obsolete we will
be a human version of a cassette tape
when all the kids want iPods and the
kids will be basically whoever employs
the CIA all right there we go isn't this
fun isn't this [ __ ] uplifting how
about those Kansas City Chiefs bread and
circus all right hot girl and coffee
shop I like the sound of this already
old Billy boos lists that's right Billy
booth let's booze loose eighty days but
we'll be 81 by the time you listen to
this unless I go off the rails tonight
big fan of your stand-up and the podcast
all the way from Glasgow Scotland
sorry all the way from Glasgow Scotland
I'll cut to the chase Glasgow Scotland
that's where
ac/dc recorded their if you want blood
live album right in a venue that doesn't
exist anymore because I tried to find it
when I was over there I'll cut to the
chase I'm a 23 year old guy who had who
has recently graduated from college and
moved down to London about five months
ago to start a new job alright I am
enjoying life in my new surroundings and
the girls down here are of another
planet compared to back home however
there is one there is one there is one
four in particular who has caught my
attention and I'd like your advice on
the best way to ask her out
the lovely Nia's advice is welcome she
probably have a better idea of what to
do here than I would but she's not here
as I'm in Green Bay Wisconsin right now
alright she works in a coffee shop near
my work and she is immense easily a nine
point 3/10 I never have a problem with
women but 90% of the time I have had a
few beers in me at the time and my
confidence is at its peak can you give
me any advice on how to ask this girl
out giving that it's a small coffee shop
in full view of the general public
we had some chat well that's good so I
was gonna say go in there and start
talking to her and I'm 80% sure she's
into me but I'm [ __ ] myself in case
I get the rejection and there's around
30 people there to witness it dude [ __ ]
those other 30 people what you have at
your fingertips is a great story no
matter what happens you either possibly
meet the love of your life right settle
down have kids together and live happily
happily ever after or you have a
hilarious [ __ ] story dude [ __ ] that
the worst she can say is no who gives a
[ __ ] dude I'd ask her out in the middle
of the meal you know just to make the
awkwardness even further
just steer what gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] that
dude if you can chat up women it's not
because you're drunk it's because you
got rid of that stupid voice in your
head that says that you can't you
obviously can alcohol doesn't make you
talk to women
all right it doesn't make you talk to
women better when it does is it gets rid
of your [ __ ] fear so you can actually
you know perform this is like some
[ __ ] John Daly [ __ ] like he used to
have a couple of Coors Light so he'd
relax more hit the ball further
I'm not saying to go in there shit-faced
[ __ ] I gotta go back to this Kansas City
touchdown it was a pass sorry anyways
yeah dude I just go in there to [ __ ]
it's you're the man
she works in a coffee shop she's not
splitting atoms all right just go in
there all right just go in there bill
just just not even like [ __ ] try to
walk in like you're the Manny some
badass dude just [ __ ] like block out
that voice and tell me of that voice
it's gonna go great make her laugh you
know when she said I would that be all
just ask you ask it for a number do you
know you should ask [ __ ] Joe DeRosa
one time I was with Joe DeRosa you want
to talk about guy fearless
I was with Joe DeRosa one time we went
out to breakfast and the waitress came
over you know and he's kind of checking
her out or whatever and we [ __ ] even
eat enough food and he goes anything
that waitress I'm like she's cute goes
yeah he goes I think I'm gonna ask her
out and she comes back to the tables
like will that be all and he [ __ ]
asked her out right in front of me right
and she gave him his number now if she
shot him down not only it's like that
story would have left its Nike there
would just be like with you with a bunch
of strangers I could have sat there left
out of which I wouldn't have I wouldn't
two laughed at him but maybe he would
have thought that I did and he didn't
give a [ __ ] so I think you go Joe DeRosa
on this one all right listen
what is the deal you're attracted to her
you want her number to ask her out all
right so [ __ ] do that that's what you
want that's the same way you handle your
career in life what do you want to do go
do that who do you want to be with you
know that's a different thing because
they have a say but you got to ask
sit so I don't know I don't know what
your deal is if you're a funny guy
whatever your dealings I don't know
whatever you're doing it seems to be
working because you're feeling a vibe
like she's into you all right so just
stop listening to that voice girl in
like a week yeah William you did said
hey what happens if she says yes think
about that all right there you go all
right mixed-race relation now Jesus cry
let my people think I'm an expert on
this just because you know it's Lily if
I fell off a bed hey Bill you just you
fell off a bed oh I need some advice on
falling off a bed I don't know how the
hell I ended up in this relationship I
just met her and I liked her I asked her
out no I couldn't get rid of her I
didn't want to get rid of her every time
I ever thought about breaking up but
there when I was be like all in a panic
of Holly [ __ ] I mean it with her for
three months oh my god the pressure the
pressure all this pressure I was
building up on myself I would always
picture her walking out of my apartment
then even in the fantasy of getting out
of the relationship
I would always run out to go back and
get her and then it took me about a good
Oh seven eight years to realize bill
that means because you love her and you
don't want her to leave
alright hey Bill you [ __ ] alabaster
bastard alabaster bastard you alabaster
why did you do that hey Bill you [ __ ]
ala bastard I'm also a white guy who has
just started going out with the smokin
hot black chick I have no idea what she
sees in me but who gives a [ __ ] right
she makes me happy and I seem to be
happy make her happy too so it's all
good until you go outside so one of my
question as someone who's in a
successful quote mixed race I know why
it's in quotes mixed race relation I
wonder if you have any insights or
gotchas that might help my relationship
lest make my relationship last and do
you still experience any casual racism
from the mouth-breathing morons I'll
spell check this message and be careful
to use prorack punctuation too so
hopefully if you do read it you won't
sound like a preschool toddler
auditioning for Sesame Street
thanks for the podcast I listen to them
every week and go [ __ ] yourself I love
how the punctuation is my fault still
it's still my fault
I'm the victim
do I have any insights yeah this is my
insight is that you two people are
different than me and my wife because
you're an individual all right so you
know it's not like well when when like
it's like when you watch the Discovery
Channel well when dealing with the
hippopotamus there's an aggressive
behavior when it's [ __ ] partly cloudy
my advice is if you're with somebody and
they make you happy stay with them they
don't break up with them that's it all
right and if you're in that situation
right now and you want to break up with
somebody
don't use the holidays as an excuse all
right just get out now
just get out now I like to tell you it's
better to do it right before the
holidays then after okay because as much
as you're gonna [ __ ] up their
Thanksgiving Christmas Hanukkah or
Kwanzaa the new year comes and with the
new year they break you know I'm gonna
go to the gym I'm just gonna get forget
about it was the worst year ever you
know if you [ __ ] wait till after the
holidays and then boom their year starts
you just [ __ ] up their whole next year
because people think in calendar years
for whatever reason alright so getting
back to you I mean what do you want me
to say let's start listening to the
[ __ ] jay-z I will tell you this when
it comes to that [ __ ] there is still
stay in your own lane kind of thing just
because you're with her don't start
saying don't start using the expression
woke still you know I guess I can't give
you a voice there are things like that
there are things like that that no
matter how much she loves you you will
immediately turn into an annoying white
person and yes
racism doesn't magically go away because
the two of you are now together but I
will be honest with you it's just like
if it wasn't racism it would be
something else
you know I kept talking about Chicago
and Milwaukee and they kept booing
Chicago they didn't like Chicago so it's
like people oh these people don't like
their next-door neighbors they don't
like the people they work with you know
football teams don't like coaches and
GM's that won them Super Bowls so if it
wasn't that it'll be something else and
who gives a [ __ ] what other people think
you only go around once and you should
be with the person you're supposed to be
with that's what I think all right so
have fun enjoy yourselves and that's it
all right first breakup hey Billy pink
dick I don't know what does that for
some cancer thing I've been listening to
your podcast I don't know what that
means what that's funny as hell but
listening to your podcast for a couple
of years now and could really use your
advice I'm a 22 year old college senior
and recently have gone through a breakup
that's great you got it done before the
holidays so she got it done we dated for
six months and it was great she was my
first girlfriend and my first love she
was even the first girl I ever had sex
with all right she not checked it all
off but as we neared six months I began
to worry about committing to a long term
relationship when I've never even had
sex with another woman my dick got cold
feet and rightly so rightly so because
as a guy if you think in that [ __ ]
you're gonna eventually do it so why
hurt her anyway so long after so after a
long talk we decided to break up I
thought having sex for the first time
was tough but breaking up for the first
time is horrible yes it is yes it is I
can't seem to get out of this funk it's
really hard not to miss her what advice
you have for someone going through their
first breakup my friends and I have gone
to a bar only once or twice since and
none of us have any game we stand around
the corner of the bar looking like
meerkats
that's hilarious it's the last corner of
the game and I'm down ten points I could
use a motivational speech from Coach
ginger pubes over here thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself
all right we obviously have a sense of
humor yeah it's a deal - my advice when
you're going through a breakup is rather
than doing the guy thing and trying to
block it out like it isn't happening go
through the sadness of it
all right don't cry in front of your
friends but if you got to cry cry it out
of you it's actually a healthy thing
crying is a healthy emotion I finally
figured that out you know when I haven't
you know cried in almost 50 [ __ ]
years so now it's like no longer like I
don't know it's like a room that I
walled off I mean literally a friend of
mine has to die I have to be at a
[ __ ] funeral you know what I mean
but anyways don't run from the pain of
it okay that's what women do women when
they [ __ ] break up they don't [ __ ]
run right on for the most part they
don't run right out and get into
something else they stay home they watch
sad movies they listen to sad [ __ ]
they listen to set oh my god the Chiefs
just did a potato sack race
celebration dance I was actually rooting
for them this year I was like Anna be
cool to see them maybe win it you know
the Patriots ours mediocre as they look
and I got to say [ __ ] that whole
franchise if not the whole state I'm
glad the st. Louis Cardinals moved I'm
even going to take st. Louis down that
was the it's one of the worst things
I've ever seen
now of course show it again well
if remember like the dunking contest
when people just out of ideas Sousa says
it's enough already just spike the ball
like Gronk and go back to the sideline
boy oh Jesus huh I gotta walk that one
off you know when you got to have like a
[ __ ] separate meeting with for the
teammates to get your endzone dance
together I mean just I don't know
anyways yeah what women do correctly is
they they when they're sad they allow
themselves to be sad if they have to cry
they allow themselves to cry and you
actually feel better after you do that
stuff it's when you ignore it and you
push it down if it comes this [ __ ]
weight in your chest or this [ __ ]
ball of [ __ ] in your head you broke up
with somebody and you said so I would be
sad and then as far as going out to a
bar you know I mean I don't know how do
you learn how to throw a football the
first time you throw a football if you
don't throw a tight spiral do you just
never throw one again you keep doing it
and it gets better you got to go out
there and uh we used to [ __ ] wait on
that we score this place Daisy Buchanan
said I guess is a legendary meat market
on Newbury Street in Boston and we used
that we used to just [ __ ] you went in
there like it was almost like a stand-up
comedy thing well you just went up and
like deliberately tried to bomb to make
your friends laugh we used to go in
there and just any dumb [ __ ] thing we
could think of as we just kept doing it
and doing it and doing it and it it
stopped being the way we got over the
fear because it is the fear of rejection
is [ __ ] brutal when you're young
right so what we did is we would hit on
some chick while other buddy could hear
it so if you started bombing and she
wasn't in it you could then just switch
over to trying to make your friend laugh
by making even more of a fool of
yourself and then all of a sudden
rejection became funny it didn't become
this like oh my god is there something
wrong with me I want to run out of here
don't ya young you're 22 years old you
know yeah
III don't even how to say it it's just
like I would hit on every cute chick you
saw you know I'm not saying to go out
there and be a [ __ ] man [ __ ] but
you're single and I mean college life
that's like the greatest [ __ ]
nightclub ever everybody's single
everybody's young and good-looking I
mean there's no reason that's not the
time to be shy
get over your shyness and just [ __ ]
throw it out there and see who gives a
fool gives a [ __ ] the worst thing is
that they say no and you keep coming
back let me [ __ ] times I bombed
before I got to this level of being able
to do my [ __ ] and dick jokes alright
anyways oh god now they're just gonna
keep showing the potato sack they've
shown it like three [ __ ] times
anyways
well you know what I'm not I'm not gonna
be the crabby old man good for those
guys and I'm gonna keep rooting for the
Kansas City Chiefs because I know
there's long diehard fans they got that
[ __ ] great Stadium
I'll walk that off and just say you know
what built the NFL continues to change
and a new generation has come in and
this is how they celebrate touchdowns
and don't be the grumpy old man get the
ball back to the ref I'm not gonna be
that guy all right great
let's see a three-legged race next all
right god bless him god bless them god
bless DJ music
god bless the CIA and whatever they're
doing with the robots all right that's
the podcast for this week go [ __ ]
yourselves and I will check in on you on
Thursday I'm going to upload pictures of
some of the [ __ ] that I did in Milwaukee
and some of the Harley Davidsons and all
that type of [ __ ] and I know there was
something else all the Pfister hotel the
unfortunately names Pfister hotel I'll
upload all of that [ __ ] all right that
is it I'll talk to you later